Donald Trump has a Secretary of Commerce
named Wilbur Ross Wilbur Ross is very
very rich he's previously claimed a net
worth of up to 3.7 billion dollars
forbes has been able to I guess verify
just under three billion dollars of that
alleged net worth previously and they
that's what they've published he is so
wealthy and so connected to so many
areas of American industry that he was
specifically asked during his
confirmation hearings how are you going
to avoid conflicts of interest and he
said quote I intend to be quite
scrupulous about recusal and any topic
where there is the slightest scintilla
of doubt you can only do that if you
fully disclosed your assets and we've
now learned that Wilbur Ross did not
fully disclose his assets he put assets
that is he pulled quite a move between
election day and inauguration day where
he moved about two billion dollars in
assets into trusts for his family and
completely left them off of his
financial disclosure report how do we
know if there are conflicts if the
assets have been moved and not been
disclosed how was this uncovered well
this is just so funny Forbes has been
covering Wilbur Ross's wealth for a very
long time and they realized all of a
sudden that he used to say he had 3.7
billion dollars and now all of a sudden
he has less money how did that happen
they went to Ross's staff for an
explanation and it turns out that Ross
Wilbur Ross once said oh no you know
what I did
I moved the assets into trusts for my
family and of course that you're not
allowed to do that if you do that you're
supposed to still disclose that and the
reason is that there are complex and
sophisticated ways to move assets into
trusts where they will eventually come
back to you and there's a few different
ways that you can line this up and any
of us can tell that
if you move specific assets into a trust
number one you know what they are so it
doesn't really prevent conflicts of
interest we saw that happen with Donald
Trump as well and number two if you set
it up so that those assets will
eventually come back under your personal
financial umbrella it really doesn't do
much to prevent you from acting in the
interests of growing those assets now
Wilbur Ross's staff is saying never
happened
nope he never did that there was a
misunderstanding he never did that
Forbes is being very clear about this
Forbes says that they went to Wilbur
Ross and this is just amazing they said
you know Wilbur
we're going to have to remove you from
the rich of the four up from the list of
the 400 richest people in the United
States because you used to have this
amount of wealth and now you have this
amount of wealth and Wilbur Ross says
that's fine as long as you put in that
the reason why my wealth has gone down
is that I put my assets into a trust the
guy is so enamored with the idea of
being this wealthy person that it got
him to admit to wrongdoing and you can
say well Wilbur Ross did nothing wrong
because after all once he transfers the
assets they're no longer his assets to
disclose that's wrong federal law
specifically says if you're an incoming
cabinet member you need to disclose not
only the assets that you currently own
but also any that produced income during
the current and previous calendar year
even if you do not own them so federal
law said he was supposed to disclose
disclose the two billion dollars who
else that this is an understandable
thing right I I almost forgot two
billion dollars the other day as well
come on who believes this and I actually
that this story makes me question why
Wilbur Ross is even working for Donald
Trump
three point seven billion dollars almost
eighty years old
can you really line your friends pockets
that much as Secretary of Commerce that
it's worth leaving this incredibly cushy
lifestyle to be subjected to this level
of scrutiny maybe you can maybe you can
and that's
why he's doing it but just remember that
Republicans made Jimmy Carter get rid of
his peanut farm because of a possible
conflict of interest this is 2 billion
dollars and nothing will come of it
even though we keep hearing about drain
the swamp right it's never been filled
more quickly than under the Trump
administration discuss this or any other
topics from today's show with us at
david pakman.com slash re d di t the
video you just watched was made possible
by support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as $1 per
month and every dollar helps to support
the work that we're doing particularly
in light of the YouTube ad boycott which
has been really bad